she is a Las Vegas favorite and now she
has a new web series on YouTube please
welcome Melody sweets and her executive
producer and director Ani tamasian and
we're so excited to have you guys here
early early in the morning we appreciate
your time so this new web series it's um
burlesque and baking do I have that okay
and and Melody of course you're well
known here in the community for your
incredible um your incredible talents on
the stage I believe you started in Vegas
as the green fairy right with absence
okay so this is a new Venture ladies
tell me what can folks expect in this
web series it is a wild baking show it
has tons of Las Vegas characters
starring in it it's a six episode series
there's lots of baking tips there's some
crazy bakes in it okay oh and here's
some of the video so we're seeing a
little a little snippet there are
puppets naughty puppets it's not a kid's
show but there are puppets so and as I
said burlesque and baking so we're
thinking you know 18 and over
it is she knows that naughty but it's
you know maybe the comedy is a bit adult
okay for kids we cross them we cross
lines or step on them at least okay
okay but not only do you get to have a
little fun too but but if I want to
learn a baking something I'm gonna learn
something yes okay definitely yeah 10
recipes and stuff like that will be
coming later so we're excited to share
all of that and I think we wanted to
just bring our perspective to the baking
World a little bit right like we wanted
to make it playful we want to make it
exciting
um and funny and just kind of not take
it too seriously and
um less Martha Stewart more fun we
definitely have a lot of fun good yes I
cannot wait to release the bloopers so
you've released one episode already you
said there's six total where can people
go to find the web series if they want
to watch uh you can go to YouTube at
Sweet Spot TV okay and also you can go
to our website Sweet Spot tv.com www you
don't have to see it sweet spot okay so
that's uh that's where you're gonna go
it's about a 10 minute 10 minute serious
plenty of time to enjoy wherever yeah
you're on the bathroom you have your
phone in your hand oh my gosh easy
enough you know just like put it on it's
easy yeah I'm excited to take a look at
that now also Folks at home uh you got
to stay tuned because Melody is going to
perform for us so so stick around you're
gonna be singing so yeah all right well
again thank you for waking up early hang
tight follow